I'm a financial advisor who specializes in divorce.
The only way a triad marriage ends well for the wife
is if the husband dies before he meets the new woman
with a life insurance policy.
Not my words. Read the comment
from women who have the lived experience
to experts in every field surrounding divorce and marriage
and financial and anything you could fucking imagine.
People who are removed from the situation
and who have no interest in what happens to you
will tell you the dead ass truth.
That the tried marriage is only gonna serve the husband.
Traditional roles only serve the husband.
And in the end,
the person who's most vulnerable and most at risk is the woman.
In those situations, the people closest to you,
who are gonna keep you to these, like,
societal standards, they're gonna push you into this shit.
The boyfriend that you're dating,
who's gonna benefit from your unpaid labor.
Of course he's gonna push you into a tribe marriage.
Of course he's gonna sell you the fucking dream.
He wants you to become his personal servant.
Bang! Made housekeeper,
nanny, everything.
If it sounds too good to be true,
it usually is. So, again,
I'm gonna go back to the same thing I always say.
We don't raise our little boys to say, hey,
when you grow up, you know,
just find a friend that you can make an arrangement with
and live with him. That's totally available.
Option for life. You do not need to go to college,
get an education, learn any of this mumbo jumbo bullshit.
We would never raise our sons that way.
And we are doing our daughters a huge disservice by.
By telling them that their greatest service in life
is not to just serve a man.
There's. We have so much more to offer.